[Music]  party Hannity Lynette give it something  socially responsible can't we just let  it go missing these Minetta adapt Murph  okay miss mascot like the rest of us  [Music]  this was a treasured it's been talents  to leave for a while now  your daughter's generation will be the  last to survive on earth you're the best  pilot we ever had get out there a safer  world  nobody really say goodbye to our solar  system to our galaxy here we go  here  [Music]  I get down fast I might actually want to  get there in one piece I know  [Music]  we have a mission our mission does not  work but the people on earth they're  dead by the time we pull it off  we let this fun rather than any human in  history well not far enough  like a cow  as I have now  all right yes you are yes you are  you might have to decide between senior  children again in the future of the  human race  we always have